[Musique]
dans les profondeurs le plus noir de
l'esprit existe une cage dont les
prisonniers ne savent ni qui ils sont ni
combien ils sont de cette cellule la
fuite est difficile
ce sont des personnes qui souffrent du
trouble de la personnalité multiple de
dépression de suicide de changement de
personnalité ou de perte de mémoire
durant des années il était incompris et
non soignées en cours aujourd'hui
nul ne sait pourquoi l'esprit se dérègle
en plusieurs personnalités au lieu d'une
normalement
[Musique]
l'origine de l'arrivée de la
personnalité multiple vient souvent de
l'enfance mais se développe beaucoup
plus tard les dérèglements surviennent
généralement après une expérience
traumatisante
un matin de janvier 1988
gary un fermier le 41 ans dans le week
en chine se réveille et fixe sa femme
d'un oeil vide
[Musique]
curieux bon cop gary s'est réveillé en
regardant tout autour de lui les regards
de celui qui ne sait plus où il est
qu'il est cela m'a fait un terrible choc
nawak
ce n'était pas garé c'était quelqu'un
d'autre ça devient un autre homme que je
ne connaissais pas la voix de gary était
plus douce avec des intonations féminine
sa femme catherine se sentait de plus en
plus effrayé au lieu de s'habiller avec
les vêtements de garris cette personne
est allé dans ma penderie pour prendre
mes vêtements
alors je me suis dit il faut que je
sache ce qui se passe et surtout je dois
éloigné garine la maison nous avons donc
rouler au hasard toute la journée
n'importe où où gary disait à catherine
qu'il n'avait aucune idée de qui est
l'été ni de leurs six enfants
mais il prétendait être une femme
s'appelle en mairie j'ai cru que gary
était devenu complètement fou mais ce ne
pouvait être regardé cette personne ne
connaissait pas les enfants ne savait
rien de sa vie
home est un véritable baume est ouest
gary passer pour un homme travailleur
aimons sa femme et ses enfants
ce n'était plus l'homme qu'elle avait
épousé 20 ans plus tôt
[Musique]
quand catherine et gary était jeunes et
nouveaux mariés ils savaient exactement
ce qu'ils voulaient une grande famille
une petite laiterie des enfants dès les
premières années était tout ce qu'ils
avaient souhaité je me souviendrai
toujours de nos techniques de nos
balades ou partie du foot
parce que mon père était toujours dans
le coup mes meilleurs souvenirs sont
toujours nous nous tous ensemble juste
dans le bonheur simple d'être en famille
[Musique]
mais ce bonheur a été brisée al'annonce
du cancer du cerveau de leur fille aînée
chrissy âgée de 8 ans
les docteurs lui donner quelques
semaines à vivre may cry si les a fait
mentir en s'accrochant à la vie
[Musique]
gary et catherine passèrent tout leur
temps à s'occuper de leur fille aînée
mais les frais médicaux entraînèrent
leur faillite et en 1978 ils sont
obligés de louer une petite maison
appelée de ville dans le wisconsin
[Musique]
quatre ans plus tard chris y comptera
qu'une pneumonie et doit être emmenée
d'urgence à l'hôpital toute la nuit gary
veille devant sa porte pour petits
matins pendant l'introduction d'un
moniteur cardiaque
chrissy fait un arrêt cardiaque gary à
regarder impuissant sa fille mourir
malgré les efforts de réanimation
tsf s'empaler chez comme si quelqu'un
vous avait enfoncé un coin joue dans le
coeur
rien n'est comparable ces douleurs c'est
sans doute à ce moment là que la
personnalité de gary a commencé à
vaciller
ce fut un terrible vide dans la vie de
gary et catherine catherine s'étaient
réfugiés dans les livres tandis que gary
semblait préparer ce changement brutal
de personnalités
à l'âge de 36 ans gary qui n'avait
jamais été excellent à l'école car
dyslexiques voulait reprendre des études
de médecine
[Musique]
le changement des deux parents inquiéter
leurs enfants sourire après la mode
christie sont mamans dans sa chambre et
papa jamais la soie est recherchée du
travail soit il travaillait soit il
étudiait la famille vécu ainsi durant
cinq ans jusqu'à l'obtention d'un
diplôme universitaire pour gary et d'un
autre traumatisme qui cette fois le
ferait basculer
le médecin de catherine lui annonce
qu'elle était atteinte d'un cancer des
ovaires phase terminale il s'avère très
vite que le diagnostic était une erreur
4 il ne courait en réalité aucun danger
mais pour gary c'était plus qu'il n'en
pouvait supporter la pensée qu'il aurait
pu perdre aussi sa femme d'un cancer la
briser c'est à ce moment là que gary à
disjoncter à cuba je suis rentrée de
l'hôpital exténué
il m'avait été annoncé que je devais
mourir
vous accusez ces mêmes médecins vous
annonce que tout va bien je me suis
sentie comme anesthésié puis je ne me
souviens plus de rien à son réveil le
lendemain
catherine trouve un étranger à côté
d'elle dans son lit qui lui dit
s'appeler mairie catherine menu méfiante
à l'égard de tous les docteurs ne le
conduit pas chez un psychiatre
[Musique]
si je n'avais pas eu des problèmes avec
receipts et mes propres problèmes
peut-être aurais-je agi différemment
mais à l'époque j'avais peur des
médecins j'aurais dû foncé à l'hôpital
après une semaine de vide total gary a
quitté sa maison pour vivre dans le
milwaukee trouve un appartement et un
travail et maintenant la vie d'une femme
plus tard gary prendra une autre
personnalité celle d'un bébé et sa
maladie mystérieuse sera finalement
diagnostiqué par un froid matin de
février 1988 une famille de louise can
si nous perdra son père non la suite
d'un décès ou d'un divorce mais à la
suite d'un cas de personnalités
multiples non-encore diagnostiqués
[Musique]
gary a quitté son domicile en disant
être une femme nommée mére il a déménagé
dans le milwaukee et a travaillé dans
une exploitation d'équipements lourds
tous ses nouveaux amis pensaient qu'il
était une femme gwen c'était
effectivement une forte femme mais elle
était bien coiffé bien maquillé les
ongles faits elle dégageait de la
douceur de la réserve et possédait d'une
grande féminité mais une petite ville
comme celle que gary avait quitté
n'était pas prête à accepter cette
mystérieuse transformation les voisins
considéraient gary comme un travesti ou
un fou
[Musique]
catherine a pensé trouver une aide au
sein de son église catholique mais elle
a été rejetée
puis pour les gens de mon propre groupe
de prière avant d'abandonner ce sens
devant le tabernacle
l'un d'entre eux m'a même dit vous
feriez mieux de prier avec nous et là
j'ai plutôt pensé oh mon dieu n'est pas
un autre talent catherine fut forcé de
vivre en reclus
que voulez vous que nous fassions tout
chemin comment les enfants vous vêtir
dire à leurs voisins et amis
mon père est parti et maintenant c'est
une personne qui porte des robes j'ai
menti à tout le monde
gary était parti dans le milwaukee et si
quelqu'un des volumes plus de détails
je lui aurais dit qu'il était quelque
part et que je ne savais pas sur moi
trois mois après le départ de gary
d'échecs et de gentils lettre demandant
des nouvelles des enfants sont arrivés à
la maison
elles étaient toutes signées mairie
jusqu'à quel point mari se souvenait
qu'elle avait une fallait les tuer il
s'adressait à moi comme une soeur mais
catherine ne se doutait pas encore de ce
qu'il advenait de son mari gary a vécu
comme mairie jusqu'à ce qu'ils se
sentent à peu perturbé et recherche
l'aide d'un psychothérapeute chic elle
est arrivée à la clinique et tout de
suite j'ai vu dans son regard ce
désordre intérieur qu'il animait cet
homme qui disait s'appeler mairie ne
comprenait pas pourquoi ils avaient des
organes masculins les évaluations
psychologiques ont montré qu'ils avaient
eu des trous de mémoire énorme et qui ne
se souvenait de rien avant son fameux
réveil de ce matin auprès de sa femme
catherine résultats je lui ai demandé si
elle pouvait d'appeler un membre de sa
famille pour parler avec nous car je ne
savais plus quoi faire d'autre a décidé
de ne pas revoir le thérapeute mais de
rester en contact avec catherine
catherine voulant maintenir la relation
avec son époux est devenue la meilleure
amie de mairie
en deux ans catherine a réussi à
convaincre mairie de venir vivre avec
elle et les enfants
ils ont acheté une vieille ferme et
quelques vaches laitières
les enfants étaient d'accord pour
appeler leur père tente mairie mais
cette solution fut dévastatrice je
faisais des caprices pour ne pas aller à
l'école
je disais que mon père en était la cause
et que je pensais que je n'arriverai
jamais à rien mais en réalité si je
pleurais beaucoup c'est que je ne
voulais tout simplement pas sortir de
chez moi parce qu'à ce moment là les
gens vraiment été méchant avec moi ils
vécurent ainsi trois années difficiles
abandonné par les parents et les amis
catherine désespéré de trouver un jour
une solution à son problème mairie
accepte enfin de retourner voir son
psychothérapeute gretchen fink catherine
l'accompagnera catherine a commencé à me
rapporter ce qui s'était vraiment passé
et j'ai pensé qu'il ne s'agissait pas
d'un trouble d'identité mais de quelque
chose du même genre
ce quelque chose du même genre est
devenu beaucoup plus clair ce matin où
gary maintenant encore la vie d'une
femme nommée mairie s'est électrocuté en
faisant de travaux à la ferme
[Musique]
lorsqu'elle a ouvert les yeux j'ai vu un
étranger ce regard perdu qui cette fois
encore ne me reconnaissez parc
cet homme de 47 ans pouvait à peine
parler et marcher
garric n'était plus mairie c'était
désormais un bébé catherine appelé créé
john king qui lui a conseillé de foncer
à l'hôpital devant la peur de 4 in fine
que a bien voulu les retrouver là bas je
suis entré dans la pièce et j'ai vu
cette personne que je connaissais depuis
maintenant cinq ans qui me regardait
comme si elle ne m'avait jamais vu
c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai pensé aux
troubles de la personnalité multiple
dès qu'une personne présente deux
personnalités totalement distinctes elle
peut être considéré comme possédant ce
trouble psychologique en devenant un
bébé après avoir été une femme
on savait de quoi souffre est guéri
si c'était un soulagement pour la
famille ce n'était pas une guérison pour
garer il s'occupait de lui comme d'un
bébé il buvait des biberons et manger la
nourriture des nourrissons puis un matin
huit semaines plus tard aussi
mystérieusement qu'il avait disparu gary
est revenue à 6 noeuds pendant six ans
et demi
nous n'avons ni vu ni par les agarics et
tout d'un coup il s'est réveillé son
dernier souvenir était celui de la mort
de sa fille crie si à cette date
j'ai dit ils ont tué christie's elle
était à l'hôpital des internes ont voulu
lui poser un stimulateur cardiaque sans
autorisation c'était en pleine nuit et
ils ont provoqué un arrêt cardiaque
quand j'ai revu mes enfants pour la
première fois je n'arrivais pas à croire
mais si grand et je ne les connaissais
pas je devais apprendre à les connaître
à nouveau deux mois après sa guérison
gary et catherine ont renouvelé leur
promesse de mariage
pour gary la découverte de son trouble
de personnalité multiple le laisser
plein de remords
il se sentait coupable de tout ce temps
passé loin de sa famille hi fi j'ai
l'impression d'avoir abandonné mes
enfants de ne pas avoir été près de et
d'avoir aussi abandonné catherine ma
femme que j'ai laissé seul avec toute
cette peine mais je n'y peux rien je
suis c'était juste un dysfonctionnement
de mon corps qui se partageait en 2 3 et
que sais-je encore le trouble de la
personnalité multiple est l'une des
maladies les plus mystérieuses de
l'esprit en ce qui concerne de gary
pourquoi at il vécu ces différentes
personnalités quels en étaient les
causes
les psychiatres expliquent ce phénomène
étrange de plusieurs façons certaines
personnes développent ce genre de
personnalité alternative
en réponse à un trop grand traumatisme
ou à une trop importante tension
il appelle ce processus la dissociation
people sport les gens sous tension parle
d'une sensation de vide comme s'il
n'était plus le même
mais lors d'une tension extrêmement
forte
il y as cassure dans l'esprit lviv
réellement ce qu'il des crises mais ils
n'en sont plus conscients ils ne peuvent
plus analysé leurs émotions
comme vous pourrez le faire une personne
qui a un esprit sain
beaucoup restent inexpliquées au sujet
de ces désordres mentaux mais une chose
est sûre tous les cas de troubles de
personnalité multiple proviennent de
traumatismes de l'enfance
pour gary d'après sa femme il aurait
subi des abus sexuels et ainsi que pour
beaucoup son trouble s'est révélé lors
d'un traumatisme à l'âge adulte
l'horrible douleur de regarder sa fille
mourir l'a sans doute conduit à se
dissocier de son statut d'adulte
aujourd'hui gary ne se souvient pas de
ces six années comme mairie ni de
l'université une perte de mémoire quasi
totale de 11 ans en prenant une autre
personnalité les malades puis leur
tension ou leurs traumatismes et n'ont
donc plus à y faire face et à les gérer
c'est comme un système d'auto défense en
cas de grand danger
il est difficile de dire pourquoi gary a
choisi de revenir son psychologue
explique pour quelques raisons
inconscientes gary s'est senti
suffisamment forts pour affronter la
vérité
désormais gary se calme lui même quand
il se sent tendu
même si sa famille affirme qu'elle est
prête à vivre avec la partie de marie en
lui la partie du bébé je les aime tous
les trois ils sûr je préfère mon papa et
vous savez nous n'avons pas le choix
nous devons l'accepter je ne vais pas
mentir
j'espère seulement que si quelque chose
arrive il ne sera pas longtemps marie où
le bébé parce que c'est quand même
totalement irréaliste
[Musique]
c'est comme l'épée de damoclès au dessus
de votre tête vous ne savez jamais de
quoi leur sous la minute suivante sera
fait vraiment quelquefois vous avez une
peur bleue maintenant examinons le cas
d'une jeune fille dont la personnalité
alternative
et suicidaire
le trouble de la personnalité multiple
est difficile à diagnostiquer parce que
le plus souvent cachés au fond de
l'esprit qui lui même lutte pendant des
années contre la dépression les
tendances suicidaires la drogue ou
l'alcool
la personne mène souvent une vie
tourmentée et désespéré qu'en valais
leader qui n'avait 16 ans c'était une
droguée et une alcoolique elle a
traversé l'enfance à philadelphie entre
abus sexuels et traumatismes
valérie s'est toujours sentie en conflit
avec ses demi soeurs et sa mère
alcoolique
nous vivions dans une ambiance
terrifiante et imprévisible la violence
est classée avec les coups et je ne
savais jamais pourquoi qu'ils avaient
tort ou raison
et est-ce ma mère et mes soeurs lorsque
je suis devenu adulte mais soeur était
odieuse avec moi et ma mère bus verts
aussi je me sentais assez perturbé je ne
savais plus très bien où j'en étais nqi
jeune fille valérie a bien essayé de se
sortir de tous ses démons en assistant
toutes les semaines à des discussions et
des rencontres avec un psychothérapeute
mais aucun résultat elle a commencé à
ressentir des vides et des pertes de
mémoire et bientôt une autre
personnalité a surgi menaçant sa vie
valérie se rappelle très bien avoir
marché dans un petit couloir exigu et de
s'être blotti dans un coin mais elle ne
se souvient pas d'avoir englouti 60
caché dans le cabinet médical de sa mère
elle s'est juste senti comme une toute
petite fille je me sentais tellement
vulnérable et blessés j'avale et en
demandant juste à dieu de me pardonner
mais je ne pouvais faire autrement je ne
voulais pas vraiment mourir et je ne
savais même pas pourquoi j'étais dans ce
cabinet médical
sa mère l'a trouvé et lui a sauvé la vie
valérie est rentrée chez elle
elle a continué le collège et deux ans
d'université avant d'avoir à nouveau
besoin dead
cette fois ci elle demande elle-même son
internement dans un hôpital
psychiatrique de l'arizona
valérie est déclarée maniaco dépressive
et son traitement médicamenteux est très
lourd ce qui la met dans un état et bt
est souvent dépressif à sa sortie elle
revient avec joie à l'université à cette
période
elles étaient épanouis et calme je me
sentais bien
j'aimais cet univers de compétition de
travail de défis et tous ceux -
d'universitaires pendant toutes ces
années j'étais très heureuse mais vers
la fin de ses études supérieures
valérie subi un brusque changement son
intérêt pour sa scolarité s'amenuisent
elle passe ses nuits dehors
[Musique]
une amie d'université vous voyez bien la
personnalité de valérie évolué mais elle
a pensé que cela me était juste un peu
lunatique dos quand nous perdions de vue
parfois des mois ou juste quelques
semaines mais quand je la revois y est
je ressentais toujours cette impression
elle était différente sur de nombreux
points elle n'avait plus la même vision
des choses les mêmes centres d'intérêt
les mêmes amis et même sa garde-robe et
échanger puis un soin valérie se
trouvant d'humeur enjouée a décidé
d'aller danser avec une amie et soudain
alors que la soirée sans m'est agréable
de façon totalement inexplicable valérie
devient suicidaire
[Musique]
j'étais à jeun vous savez je n'avais
rien vu
j'étais juste là dans cette boîte j'ai
regardé mon ami et lui ai dit je veux
ouvrir le ventre
et pourtant je ne voulais pas mourir
elle a tout de suite pensé que nous
devions aller aux urgences aux urgences
valérie agissiez au début comme une
petite fille puis cette personnalité
d'adultes à émerger le médecin lui a
demandé si on lui avait déjà dit qu'elle
était à thème de personnalités multiples
sa voix valérie a répondu non non je
n'ai pas plusieurs personnes au fond de
moi elle m'a juste regarder avec
gentillesse en souriant parce que je ne
savais pas que ces personnalités lui
avait parlé après cet incident le
psychiatre de philadelphie a
diagnostiqué que valérie souffrais du
trouble de la personnalité multiple elle
a passé les trois années suivantes avec
de lourds soins en externe mais vers la
fin valérie ne se soigner même plus
[Musique]
de ce fait dans l'année et demie qui
suivit son psychiatre a découvert une
cinquantaine de personnalités
alternative sous hypnose
valérie a révélé son enfance terrifiante
d'abus sexuels et de culte satanique
un après midi en faisant le ménage dans
son appartement valérie a découvert un
journal et des dessins qu'elle avait
réalisé sous une de ses personnalités
alternative les écrits et les dessins
torturé long épouvanté son état a empiré
elle se rendait compte qu'il avait
besoin d'une nouvelle forme le
traitement
[Musique]
à 36 ans valérie entre à l'hôpital chatr
de dallas afin de trouver un traitement
pour la soigner
les médecins se concentrent alors sur
ses problèmes actuels plus que sur son
passé son début valérie ne croyait pas
qu'elle souffrait de troubles de la
personnalité
aussi at elle demandé un suivi vidéo de
sa thérapie ici nous voyons une de ses
personnalités relâchant toutes ces
émotions profondes
[Applaudissements]
dix minutes plus tard apparaît une
petite fille apeurée
ouais mon papa ouais mon papa en ont et
valérie birkin je veux savoir où est mon
papa le passage en petite fille durera
45 minutes
la découverte par son docteur de la non
vérité de son souvenir d'enfant sur le
satanisme fut un moment décisif dans la
thérapie de valérie ses souvenirs aurait
sans doute été suggérée lors de son
premier passage sous hypnose
cette révélation lui permit de se
consacrer uniquement sur la seule cause
de son dérèglement émotionnel l'abus
sexuel
[Musique]
valérie souligner deux points elle a eu
très tôt des problèmes sérieux dans sa
vie qui ont entraîné des symptômes de la
personnalité multiple mais il apparaît
aussi que la thérapie peut parfois
amplifié et augmenter les dérèglements
les rendant pire qu'ils ne le sont après
18 mois les barrières entre ses
personnalités multiples on semblait
s'atténuer
ce processus appelé intégration peut
être long et douloureux
la guérison des troubles de la
personnalité multiple est similaire à
celle de l'alcoolisme
vous devez le vouloir réellement être
vraiment motivé et vous devez savoir que
vous aurez à accomplir un travail de
force
si vous êtes bien préparé alors vous
pourrez réussir valérie n'a pas
totalement récupéré
elle n'est pas encore complètement
elle-même mais ses médecins a affirmé
que les résultats sont prometteurs
comment est il possible pour valérie où
d'autres souffrent de cette même maladie
de redevenir une personne normale
j'aimerais pouvoir vous dire que les
chances de réintégration dans une vie
normale au milieu des autres de la
communauté et de ses proches est
possible mais c'est actuellement le plus
gros problème rencontré par toutes les
personnes ayant souffert du trouble de
la personnalité multiple la guérison des
patients atteints de ce trouble de la
personnalité dépend de la gravité du cas
et du psychiatre pour valérie les
diverses thérapies qui l'ont encouragé à
croire de faux souvenirs s'avérèrent
pire quand les médecins ne font pas la
distinction entre le désir inconscient
du patient et la réalité
la thérapie à graver au lieu de soulager
celle ci il est intéressant de voir que
si les thérapeutes n'agissent pas pour
le bien de leurs patients leurs avocats
interviennent
c'est en effet de plus en plus souvent
le cas maintenant les patients ou les
parents de ceux ci l'accusent leur
médecin des suites négatives de leur
thérapie cette pression permettra plus
de rigueur dans les diagnostics et les
traitements dans le cas de valérie quand
elle s'est sentie sauvé est à nouveau
dans le présent elle a commencé à aller
de mieux en mieux devait dire non à
cette maladie
vous devez vous obligez au calme vous
savez ce n'est pas évident pour
quelqu'un qui est un survivant d'un
bouleversement complet de tout son être
pour quelques uns dans la tension a
toujours été en survoltage le silence
peut être très redoutable et le calme un
stress de solitude il faut toujours
d'oser prendre ce qu'il ya de mieux dans
chaque situation
voyons maintenant la femme qui a inspiré
le livre et le film
les trois personnalités dave elle a vécu
avec différentes personnalités pendant
près de 40 ans christine moore femme
mère artiste accomplie et conférencière
a souffert du trouble de la personnalité
multiple pendant 45 ans aujourd'hui il
est complètement guéri et son parcours
est un des cas les plus fameux dans
l'histoire médicale sa douloureuse
épreuve a inspiré le livre
les trois personnalités dave et anoska
pour le film avec l'actrice zhou world
en 1957
ce film a été réalisé par son psychiatre
le docteur corbett
thigpen en 1953 en ce temps-là le
trouble de la personnalité multiple
était peu connu
ce passage relate la première bataille
de crise avec sa maladie mentale
voulez-vous continuer ainsi non pourquoi
non parce que c'est pas normal d'être
ainsi l'histoire le cri sizemore a
commencé en caroline du sud pendant la
dépression
enfant elle a été le témoin d'une série
d'événements tragiques tout d'abord à
l'âge de deux ans elle a vu le corps de
noyer dans un fossé
puis quelques semaines plus tard elle le
témoin d'un homme se faisant couper en
deux dans une scierie après ces deux
incidents un troisième un accident
survenu à sa mère ce qui dira crise
ensuite a été le déclenchement de son
désordre mental
[Musique]
à san mames ordre que j'ai vu ma mère se
couper gravement le bras et me demander
d'aller chercher mon père
sauf qu'à la plage me suis jeté sur un
lit et j'ai enfui ma tête sous
l'oreiller et alors j'ai vu cet autre
petite fille aller chercher papa c'est
là mon premier souvenir d'avoir quitté
mon corps pour le laisser à quelqu'un
d'autre part un monarque à 15 heures
à partir de là les différentes
personnalités de crise prendrait le
contrôle de sa vie
chacune avec un rôle distinct pays
e-motion les extrêmes émotionnel semble
se transformer en un personnage créé de
toutes pièces ces personnes
individuelles paraissent acquérir des
noms et des identités et finissent par
être reconnu par les autres comme des
individus réels
cet arrangement a commencé tôt dans
l'enfance de crises quand ces
personnalités se sont manifestés
elle-même par groupes de trois une
gentille petite fille une méchante et
une à différentes
[Musique]
en 1940 ce trouble n'était pas connu du
tout la famille et les amis ont juste
penser que ces problèmes venaient
seulement d'une légère tendance au
mensonge et à l'exagération crise était
mis à l'écart parce le saut nage et les
adolescents elle a quitté le collège en
classe 2 dixièmes alimentaire parce que
beaucoup de ces personnalités
alternatives ont détesté l'école
entre temps elle avait eu 21 ans était
devenu une femme et une mère
d'autres signes de sa maladie
apparaissent bien vite après son mariage
elle devenait dangereuse non pour
elle-même mais pour sa petite fille tu
as fait
ce sont des situations nouvelles de
stress qui ont fait naître ces autres
personnalités un jour ta fille alors
âgée de 4 ans s'est mise à crier crise a
pris la corde auster et a essayé
d'étrangler sa fille son mari est
intervenu crise était désorientée et a
juré qu'elle n'avait pas le moindre
souvenir de ce qui s'était passé
ces événements ont convaincu crise
d'entrée à l'hôpital d'auch gustave en
géorgie où le docteur corbett
thigpen a très vite conclu qu'elles
possèdent et trois personnalités
il les a appelés hev white f black et
jane
yves white est l épouse et la mère elle
était extrêmement puritaine tout
l'opposé de f black qui elle aimait
chanter danser boire et prendre du bon
temps
jen est d'arriver plus mûr plus
intellectuel que les deux autres est en
attente 1 0 après seulement trois ans de
thérapie
ces trois personnalités ont mué en une
seul son médecin pensait qu'elle était
guérie
entre-temps crise avait divorcé et
s'était remarié
elle avait déménagé dans le tennessee
sont qu'un flux un sujet d'étude pendant
trois ans et en 1957 le docteur tic pen
fait de ces recherches un best seller
qui devra le film
les trois personnalités dave bien que le
film et attirer l'attention du public
sur cette maladie de la personnalité
multiple crise n'en a jamais eu les
retombées financières et resta toujours
anonymes hollywood nous montre un film
qui finit bien
mais la maladie de crise au contraire
c'est développer de nouvelles
personnalités alternatives sont apparus
contraignant crise à suivre une autre
thérapie et sa famille à s'adapter à
chaque modèle
[Musique]
je reconnais c'est chaque personnalité
de ma mère et elle était toute ma mère
la dame pour prêter ma préférée
sans doute parce qu'elle se montrait
très maternelle et elle prenait soin de
moi et puis il y avait la fille aux
fraises c'était une femme stupide
arrogante dur cruel et impolie pour elle
je n'existais pas pour beaucoup les
troubles de la personnalité multiple ne
se manifeste pas seulement dans les
vêtements et les manières mais aussi par
des différences psychologiques
au fil des années la famille de crise
l'a entourée et soutenue
très vite nous avons voulu vivre comme
une famille normale et aider notre mère
nous essayons de passer par dessus de
tout faire pour atténuer diminuer ces
crises mais il nous était difficile
d'imaginer que cela pour un jour se
terminer mais en 1974 après plus de
vingt ans de thérapie crise à une
rémission
il lui semble qu'elle peut enfin
contrôler sa vie c'est arrivé d'un seul
coup voilà ce que vous devez faire
naître une personne responsable qui ne
passe pas d'un personnage à l'autre
je le désirais tellement quelqu'un de
semblable à ce que doivent être tous les
gens pour vraiment se retrouver
il lui a fallu subir des tests multiples
sur la mémoire
un bon jour l'esprit de crise se
retrouver à sa place elle se sentait
guéri je me sentais comme dans un rêve
tous intégrés tour prenait sa place
comme si je revenais à la vie pour la
famille aussi cette guérison à porte à
des changements pendant quelques mois on
a eu l'impression de vivre sur une autre
planète d'intégrer le fait que nous
ayons une mère normal je ne sentais pas
que c'était mes enfants je savais bien
qu'ils étaient bien sûr mais ces
sentiments d'amour d'attention
d'instinct maternel n'existait pas chez
moi je ne savais pas ce que c'était
aujourd'hui à plus de 70 ans crie
sizemore n'a vécu que près de 25 ans
dans la peau d'une personne normale un
homme
je sais que je suis à condenser de 22
personnalités différentes mais je suis
plus que cela aujourd'hui j'ai atteint
ma vraie personnalité durant ces 25
dernières années
les psychiatres disent bien que le plus
difficile à gérer dans une guérison et
ce passage de toutes ces personnalités
hommes seuls
quelle fut l'épreuve de crise à mort
le point commun de dans tout les
guérisons et cette sensation de perte et
de tristesse comme lorsque vous perdez 1
m
pour bon nombre de malades atteints de
personnalités multiples l'intégration
devient une sorte de deuil
ils doivent combattre la perte de mèze
malheureusement à l'heure actuelle il
n'existe aucune assurance sur la non
réapparition de ces troubles
on en fait ne savons pas ce qui se passe
quand un patient guéri at-il vraiment
récupéré de ses personnalités multiples
ou at-il encore plus de traumatismes
on imagine qu'il est plus à même de
dissocier ces différentes personnalités
à force de les connaître
ou alors toutes les thérapies subi l'ont
aidé à se sentir fort et combatif le
taux de succès de guérison des
personnalités multiples et en os mais au
regard de l'histoire du christ eyes
morts l'intégration peut être très
longue
[Musique]
j'ai mené un combat très dur pendant des
années pour guérir mais je le ferai
encore s'il le fallait car voyez vous
j'ai maintenant une vie formidable une
vraie paix que sans doute peu de gens
connaissent
le trouble de la personnalité multiple a
été révélée au grand public par le film
les trois personnalités dave mais c'est
en 1973 grâce aux livres sybille que les
gens prennent vraiment conscience du
traumatisme laissé par les abus sexuels
de l'enfance civile serait le pseudonyme
d'un étudiant en arts de l'université de
columbia à new york
l'auteur flore arrêta treiber raconte la
vie d'une femme qui ayant subies dans
son enfance des préjudices sexuelle
éclate en seize personnalités
[Musique]
d'après le livre sybille serait la
survivante d'une vie effroyable peuplé
de passage à vide brutaux et terrifiant
en 1976 une mini série télévisée tiré du
livre est apparue elle a beaucoup
contribué à faire connaître ses troubles
de la personnalité multiple jusqu'à
l'heure peu connu
25 ans plus tard au printemps 1998 un
autre cas est apparue dans les médias
pieters wealth and history en
psychanalyse et son collègue mais quelle
boersch jacobsen
un professeur de littérature à
l'université de washington découvrait
que l'inspiratrice du fameux livre et de
la série télévisée était une artiste
nommé shirley hardel maison
[Musique]
charles aimé ça ne ressemblait pas là
civile du liban fait elle s'avérer
beaucoup plus intéressante plus complexe
à la parole puisse enfin être plus
profond aussi après ces révélations
quelques toiles de mécènes sont exposées
dans une galerie à new york
pour soi health ses talents inexploités
à renforcer sa recherche et l'a
convaincu que la sibylle du roman est
effective
d'après lui shirley messone n'aurait
jamais souffert de personnalités
multiples les seize personnalités qu'il
était censé posséder aurait été
encouragé par son thérapeute le docteur
cordelia wilber il était évident que
charlène souffrait du trouble de
personnalité multiple que dans un cadre
psychothérapeutique tous ceux
connaissant charlet ne l'avais jamais vu
dans une autre personnalité
d'autre part elle aimait énormément
correspondre avec de nombreuses
personnes eh bien figurez-vous que
durant ses 11 années de psychanalyse
elle écrivait d'une manière très
cohérente et claire et elle signé
chacune de ces lettres par charles ix
être chéri
mais bien avant que sybille et
commençait à être connu elle avait
beaucoup de doutes se demandant si elle
souffrait réellement de ce trouble
le dr herbert peggle psychiatre soigner
sybille quand son thérapeute habituel
cordelia gilbert apartheid en vacances
il affirme en 1997 qu'elle ne souffre
pas de personnalité multiple elle réagit
seulement violemment sous hypnose et a
les nerfs fragiles
d'après lui les différentes
personnalités de la sibylle du livre
aurait été suggéré par une partie de la
thérapie du docteur gilbert
chez ce tell me disait serait jaylene ce
à quoi je répondais pourquoi le pensez
vous elle me répondait que lorsqu'elle
se trouvait avec le docteur wilbur il
lui semblait que c'était ce qu'elle
attendait de shirley qu'elle soit hélène
je lui disais qu'elle n'avait pas à
faire cela
elle rétorque est bien puisque je ne
peux pas le faire alors je ne le veux
pas qu elle ajouté mais est ce que c'est
bien de faire cela sans être ln oui lui
ai-je d'immédiatement spiegel ont voulu
provoquer une rencontre entre l'auteur
de sybille fleurât arrêta treiber et son
coauteur la thérapeute de mason cornelia
wilber mais elles ont décliné l'offre
lorsque j'ai affirmé que shirley ne
souffrait pas de la personnalité
multiple shreiber s'est opposée elle
disait mais si vous remettez en cause le
fait que mon héroïne soit atteinte de
cette maladie
la série ou même le livre ne se vendra
plus mon éditeur veut qu'il en soit
ainsi
je lui ai répondu ne croyez vous pas que
c'est une raison odieuse
peut-être mais sonne ne développé par
les troubles de la personnalité multiple
mais elle a pris les particularités
clinique en suivant la thérapie de son
médecin le docteur gilbert
les chercheurs pensent que dans certains
processus de la psychanalyse à leur
mutuelle peut se développer entre le
patient et son médecin
la mort de cheikh les médecins les
docteurs wilber et de schreiber empêcha
la découverte de la vérité
jusqu'à ce que les archives de wilbert
retrouver dans les années 2000
il ne faisait aucun doute comme essonne
souffrait de sérieux problèmes
émotionnels
mais jusqu'à quel point ses
personnalités multiples venait-elle
vraiment de sa thérapie
[Musique]
elle aurait pu faire semblant d'être
malade juste pour plaire aux docteurs
villemur ou prétendre ne pas l'être
alors qu'elles l'étaient pour plaire
cette fois au docteur spiegel mais nous
ne possédons pas suffisamment de preuves
pour affirmer quoi que ce soit selon le
docteur ross les tentatives pour essayer
à tout prix de trouver les troubles de
la personnalité multiple nuisent au
meilleur intérêt du patient
l'important est de sortir de l'esprit du
malade qu'il souffre de personnalités
multiples par l'analyse de ses
personnalités multiples d'insister et de
le convaincre que la personnalité
multiple ne sera jamais la réalité
désordre émotionnel est toujours créé
par l'esprit dans un but précis
la thérapie doit le découvrir et ainsi
aider le patient à vivre mieux et plus
normalement fonction way en 1980 les
troubles de la personnalité multiple
seront reconnus comme une maladie réelle
par l'association américaine en
psychiatrie mais combien de personnes en
souffrent hôtel
les experts affirment que depuis la
publication de sybille en 1973 au moins
quarante mille cas ont été recensés
presque tous en amérique du nord ayant
réussi à vaincre leurs démons intérieurs
shirley messone écrit sizemore récurent
tout à fait normalement
pour gary et valérie ils sont sur le
chemin de la guérison
beaucoup de traumatismes se forment aux
âges extrêmement vulnérables mais un
mystère reste entier
pourquoi certains enfants victimes
d'abus sexuels développe-t-il des
personnalités multiples et d'autres pas
ah non d'une façon ou d'une autre je ne
sais combien d'enfants sont victimes
chaque année de traumatismes de manière
épisodique ou répétitives mais tous ne
souffre pas ensuite de ces troubles de
personnalité multiple
la plupart d'entre eux d'ailleurs alors
pourquoi ce petit nombre nous ne savons
pas pascal a écrit un jour le coeur a
ses raisons que la raison ne connaît pas
la réponse est toujours ne savons pas
[Musique]